[Music]
the u.s manufacturing sector continued
its rebound
in july here's a way to see that a chart
showing new orders for goods that
typically last three years or longer
after declining sharply following
coronavirus lockdowns
new orders rose to about 230.7 billion
dollars in july
but still remain below pre-pandemic
levels
counting new orders for long-lasting
goods can reveal whether manufacturing
activity is expanding or contracting
that can point toward changes in the
economy's recovery
it gives you a sense of where things are
headed so it counts orders that
um in a lot of cases that retailers make
to manufacture
so if you're a retailer a major retailer
and you're ordering a bunch of products
a bunch of dishwashers that's because
they're pretty confident you're going to
be able to sell them pretty soon
the first thing to know about the
durable goods indicator is what it
measures
the number begins with a survey of about
3 100 manufacturing companies
across 92 categories in the united
states
the businesses report on how many new
orders they filled to produce
longer lasting durable goods there are
two types of goods
non-durables are consumed quickly like
paper food or gasoline
and then there are durables that count
includes construction materials like
lumber
it also includes firearms office chairs
tape measures and computer hard drives
it includes dslr cameras and vr headsets
medical equipment like
electrocardiography machines or gurneys
are durable goods too as are pieces of
fine jewelry
and books it also includes items that
are really expensive
and aren't purchased that often products
like heavy machinery
for example these conveyor belts are
durable goods
economists track the increase or
decrease in the new orders on a
month-to-month basis
if more new orders come in this month
than the last that could point toward an
economic expansion
that's because one new durable goods
order can signal future activity
to see that in action here's an example
a farm
might need to purchase a tractor so it
places an order
the tractor manufacturing company then
places orders with a number of other
companies who produce parts like
engines windshields and lights each of
those suppliers
sends orders to manufacturers for raw
materials
and other durable goods the indicator
can also capture the ripple effects from
a bigger
national trend like housing sales i
suppose say home sales are doing really
well like it turns out they are right
now
it's conceivable it's possible that a
bunch of people are going to start
buying
long lasting appliances for their homes
and
that in turn will cause the retailers
these long lasting appliances to
to order more from manufacturers the
durable goods survey
captures the manufacturing activity
that's connected to business activity
in this case the purchase of a home
many manufacturers track these new
orders and send the data to the census
bureau
most of the manufacturers in the survey
have 500 million dollars or more in
annual shipments
but it also includes some smaller firms
to make the sample more representative
economists investors and analysts watch
for changes in the numbers which are
released monthly
the main use really is it feeds into the
gdp reports
which is this very obviously very
closely watched indicator
durable goods can provide early insight
into economic patterns
but the indicator is not without flaws
of the many items that are counted in
this survey
some are outweighed and can obscure
changes elsewhere in manufacturing
one thing to keep in mind about the
drupal goods report is that it's very
volatile and
the sources of volatility are things
like like aircraft
to see a better proxy for business
investments you can look at the
non-defense capital goods excluding
aircraft
it's a subsection of the durable goods
survey that gives you a better sense of
kind of the
of the trend which is really what we're
looking for here excluding aircraft
makes a significant difference in the
data
for example in some cases a new boeing
jetliner can cost between 50 million
to over 200 million dollars and its
supply chain stretches to over 12 000
companies
but production of new boeing planes has
stalled following two fatal 737 max
crashes
and a pandemic-driven collapse in air
travel 500 jet orders were canceled this
year alone
and new orders have slowed to a trickle
boeing's troubles have overshadowed
other manufacturing activity which
skewed the durable goods survey results
it made the durable goods number look
very strange because you had all these
aircraft orders that weren't coming in
so you know a few
major categories like that can really
spew the results
public spending on defense can do the
same things that the military buys
are also included in this report so if
the pentagon puts in an order for a
bunch of fighter jets
or a bunch of tanks or something like
that you know that shows up in the
report
um it's hugely expensive it will really
sort of bump up the numbers for that
month
but it doesn't really tell you a whole
lot about the overall state of the
economy it's just the pentagon has made
a bunch of orders for tax
the durable goods survey captures
ripples of economic activity across
manufacturing
but economists look beyond the headline
number for a more meaningful view of
where things are headed